Yo what's up guys. So, um, it's pretty late right now,
but there's this guy that wrote to me, he said that he worked as a Quanta,
et cetera, and jump trading. So now I'm checking out his profile and.
Smoking weed, sipping gin and juice by the hair, the caucus. She said,
Oh, we medicated. But still as you,
Katie grew up in that. Oh wow. He goes to Harvard too.
[inaudible].
Welcome to the show, dude. Um,
I'm not going to do like the typical intro because I want this to be more of a
casual conversation. Yeah. Yeah.
Thanks for using the microphone with the weird microphone stand. Yeah. Yeah.
So can we talk a little bit about yourself? Cause I'm like interesting.
Yeah. So this is keto kid, AK little keto,
AKA ASAP keto, keto Gambino.
Are you trying to plug your child right away?
I just like try it. Alright. Go.
Okay. So the reason why I brought you here is because you have a very impressive
resume. Yeah. From what I understand, you worked at Citadel,
Instagram jumps trading. Yeah. These,
these are all like companies that got rejected from.
Exempt.
But I'm very impressed. So can you tell me, like, why did you want to come here?
Yeah, I did. I did want to plug my channel, but um,
I also did want to provide the content for like people. Um,
because I saw your brother's interview book quiet.
And so like provide for their content about the quiet and also show a side of
people in the quiet or tech spaces that are, non-traditional like me.
Like I want to show, I want to present that there are these people who.
So what do you mean? Like, I can't, I can't tell. What's so special about you.
Yeah. Uh.
Let's talk about where'd you go to college and what did you study?
Yeah. Um, so I did my undergrad in Hartford and then,
so I stayed in my bachelor's in computer science and my master's in statistics.
Oh, you have a master's too. Yeah. Are you done school? And that was cool.
I'm not, not going back anytime soon.
Yeah. Okay. So are you, are you working full-time at YouTube now? Yeah.
Or you're working full time. I thought you were still an intern. No, no, no. Oh,
I see. I see. Okay. So you work full time at YouTube.
Can you talk to me a little bit about all your previous internship till now?
I made the transition from quiet trading to tech. So I started out in,
turning out, set it out and then John and Dan, um,
and they transitioned into tech. So, um, before I started for tonight, uh,
YouTube, I interned at Instagram as well.
So, so you did set it off first then jump? Yeah. Okay. So I'd sit it out.
You were a quantity. Yes. So what did you do?
That's the dough I was into, I was looking into treasury funds.
So like one of the,
one of the popular techniques in Quan to look at correlator financial products.
So usually like a lot of like financial products don't move in sync.
The market is not perfect. And so usually when something, yeah,
someone's lagging. So some,
sometimes like one product moves and then like the other product follows quickly
after.
But then if you're able to use correlate or financial products to predict a one
that you're interested in, um, you would have some.
So wait, what was like the commodities or securities that you were trading?
The ones I was looking at was treasury bonds. Treasury bonds. Yeah. Interesting.
Yeah. Okay. So, and then it jumped trading. It was it again, treasuries?
Um, so jump training, the internship is a little bit different. So, um,
the beginning is like a little bit of training for all the interns to like get
on the same page. What kind of like Jane street, where they have fun. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. It's kind of like, it's not, it's not fine. It's more,
it's more classes, more classes. And then, um, there,
I worked on a project where I was trading market events.
So like market events or like big time events where the market is super
unstable. So like examples are like quarterly earnings or like,
uh acquirements if a company acquires another, uh.
What about when like someone tweeted about Obama,
that was like he was dead or something? Was that like a profitable day?
I guess people wouldn't expect that, but, but yeah.
Twitter is something that people also about sentimental analysis.
Stuff like that too,
because I remember from what I understand for like quant firms,
whenever there's a lot of like craziness or chaos in the market,
that's when you can profit the most.
Cause there's a lot of like exactly rationality or yeah.
Yeah. The team, the team I was on was just purely trade off of events.
Like they, they made all their money.
Yeah. So how should you prepare for those interviews?
Like what did they ask you?
Yeah, so I think, I think quite interviews are a kind of moat,
the most challenging because they include coding questions, finance questions,
and statistics questions. And usually the coding questions. Like,
have you done LICO before? Like, like the.
Other website, but just in general? Yeah.
So like usually like software interviews are like medium level problems,
but then like the quiet interviews are like medium or hard level part. So like,
so it's that they're not even asking just for like basic software skills they're
asking like for like higher level software.
Like at that point,
like it doesn't really make you a better software engineer digitally,
like tests. Are you intelligent?
Yeah. Yeah. I think cause like, I think once you get in,
like the work that you do is like,
not as near like as challenging as like the interview problems, but yeah,
I think so you just have to have like a fundamental understanding of like some
basic finance concepts and then.
Some stats. What kind of stats do you need to know?
Just like what's a portfolio or like what's a stock.
Yeah. Yeah. We're like what, where's the risk or how do you measure risk?
Or like some of these, some of these basic thoughts,
you don't have to be like as sophisticated as I can. Right.
Like it doesn't need to be like, Oh, what's the black shows model.
How do you derive that? Probably not.
They will ask you to write it, but if you have, if you know what it is. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Yeah.
And then what about, what about stats? Like what kind of questions do they ask?
Um, it's usually like your game problems.
Like if I flip a coin so many times where like, how would I,
if I have to pay for it or something like that, or like,
you're stuck in this room with this other guy.
There's always like some very like,
like obscure pawn where like you're stuck on an Island. And then they say like,
when you have these different colored hats and like, it's like, Oh,
how would I arrange the hat, such diet, escape out of prison.
It's like always like one of these like, like, like brain teaser,
like just like strep strategy problems.
Like if you're like playing games against someone.
So any extra curriculars you did when you were in school that made you
lean into finance?
Um, I actually didn't really mess with the finance groups on, in school.
I wanted to like make all my extracurriculars, like non-academic related.
Cause like there were like, obviously like a lot of professional, like clubs,
like finance clubs, tech clubs, but I didn't want to get them.
Cause then cause then like you spend all your time,
like building your career and then you don't have time for like having fun.
And so I didn't really join the.
Oh yeah. I hate it. I hated that too.
Because when your identity is based on your career or at least like that very
narrow minded career path,
it's kind of boring and honestly it doesn't make as good like
quants or data scientists or a software engineer, as you would think. Yeah.
So it's, I'm guessing you did music.
I, I use, I started music, uh, later in my senior year, but then, um,
throughout college I like kind of like, I was like in a dance troupe,
like hip hop, hip hop slash.
[Inaudible] it's okay. Yeah. Cool. So why did you switch? Why did I switch?
It seems like you were in quantum and now you're what software engineer. Yeah.
Yeah. What did I switch? Um, lost a lot of money there.
Yeah. Yeah. I did lose a lot of money. So I think there's two, two main reasons.
So one big reason is like I have a lot time now to like work on
music stuff, because like, I think like, especially when I was quiet,
like it is busy. It is very busy. It's very stressful.
I did want to find something that like gives me more opportunity to like learn
more about myself. I didn't want to just like, just like work all the time.
Right. And then the second big reason was, um,
I did think that the way finance people like thought about things was like very
limited. Everything is like just for the sake of money. And like, it felt,
it made me feel like I was losing like some human aspect,
but a lot of the people that you do meet are like kind of like emotional.
They kind of like act pure logically and rationally. Yes.
Very objective. Yeah. That makes sense. Yeah. Okay. But, um,
I hope you don't mind me asking,
how much did you get paid as a Citadel intern and jump trading and Instagram?
I can look them up if you want. I can look them up if you want. Um,
I go, go, go, go pass. It goes a little bit. Okay.
I'm gonna take a quick break and say some stuff. You know,
this video is sponsored by audible. So start your 30 day trial.
And your first audio book is free. Go to audible.com/joma.
Or if you're in the U S text Joma at 500,
500 audible content includes an unmatched selection of audio books and
other audio products. All right. Back to you,
Joma one audio books you guys should listen to is quants,
which is quite relevant to what we're talking about because it's actually, um,
it's like, it's like a true story.
And it's about all the OG quants back in the day,
how they took over wall street, for example, uh, Ken Griffin.
That was our boss at one point. Really good audio book.
You should that'd be checked out. So yeah, don't forget audible.
It's perfect for the summer times when you're just chilling at the pool.
So don't forget, you can get your 30 day free trial and one free audio book.
If you go on audible.com/joma or text Joma at 500, 500,
if you are in the U S.
So it was about, it was about, um, 10 weeks.
So 2300 a week. And then, uh, Facebook,
I want to say it was like eight K a month. Yeah, that sounds about right.
That sounds about right. Okay.
So yeah. So since you didn't do extracurricular in Quan,
how did you know about quant or want to be in school?
I was kind of like,
always like in the math competition community throughout like middle school and
high school. Yeah. So like in the math competition space,
like usually like you would have, like, you want to send by is yeah. Yeah.
So we, so we have like, uh,
like kids who are like two or three years older than us. And like,
we always look up to them.
And then in college we see like a lot of our senpai's like either going to like
academic math or like software client,
and usually like Quanta is something that's really popular with like the
competitive math people. So I got into, I got introduced to that.
And then like the interview problems are also like very representative of like
the old problems that we used to do on weird, like in high school. Uh,
so it was very natural and it's also like very competitive, like in nature.
So I guess you were always like good at math and you compete in math and stuff
like that. Yeah. Did you score well in those countries?
Uh, are you familiar with the U S competition?
Maybe they are. Maybe they are so you can say stuff and I'll just nod.
Yeah. Yeah. Uh, I, the furthest I got was to like the USA ammo,
which is like the USA, not lumpia.
It's about like 500 us students who qualify. Um,
it's part of like the it's part of like, it's part of like the track too,
like the USA I'm Latina, but I never got that far. That was too hard.
Yeah. But from what I understand, if you do want to be in quant,
you gotta be good at math, I guess.
Or do you have any other tips for people who want to be in quantum.
Um, for high school students or like college students from high school then.
And then we can talk about college, you know,
if they start it like to be a quantity college. Yeah.
I really, I really don't like the idea of like telling people what to do.
Cause like a lot of people they say like, I aspire to be X and they say like,
I have steps one, two, three, four, you. And then like,
and then if they follow those steps, they say, I read that book.
I read that book by student. I still didn't get it. And it's all because of you,
because he told me to read that book. So, but yeah, no. Yeah. You feel me?
Yeah. So, um, but I do think like in general, like it,
it still is good to like, uh,
get exposure to competitive math or just like get exposure to like,
um, just like stepping outside of like your like normal school stuff.
Cause like, I think like in school, like you don't get challenged enough. Um,
even if you're like your school doesn't offer like competitive math.
So that was like a very general approach. And honestly, I believe you like,
there's not one single path to like Quan,
but can you just tell me like one kind of path, like what she learned,
what should you major in? And then like what extracurriculars you should,
if you don't, you chose some, I'm sorry. I know,
like I hate responding to these messages too.
About how do you get suffer in general? How do you get into data science?
Especially data science. Because for me,
I mean analytics and you can do whatever you want to get analytics.
So it could be a business dude. You could be a consultant,
you could be a math major, computer science. You could do anything. Yeah.
But yeah, just give them like one little, one little spiel,
like one little path that at least you did or like that you saw other people do.
Okay. Common path, most common paths, easy.
Yeah. Like pretty much like high probability of scoring yourself. Okay. Okay.
Do you have competitive math in high school.
And you're smart. You know, don't be an idiot. You have you're smarter.
I guess. Yeah. Uh, college,
I guess the popular majors will be either pure math, applied math,
computer science, stats, physics.
In some cases I think a lot of Palm places love physics people for some reason.
And then extracurriculars. I mean,
you could go out of your way to do the finance stuff,
but then I would suggest against it because I think those are more for like
iBanking people. Yeah.
Uh, like where it's all about networking and like seeing if you're.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I think that's pretty good.
Or they teach you how to network with people.
They have classes just purely goes for that.
Cause like that's like a critical part to your like yeah.
Yeah. Well, I guess that it's it's um, enough about Quan.
I want to talk more about like your personal life, more about like your, uh,
your career in rapping or sorry. As an artist.
I think for every rapper, I'm not a rapper. I'm the artist. Yeah.
But every rapper is okay. I'm going to stop you here. Wait,
what's the problem of calling you a rapper. What's the what problem?
Cause I don't want to get this.
Oh, okay. Oh you ain't rapper. Yeah. I don't, I don't want,
I don't want to drama. I, I just want to be an artist.
In your career in rapping.
Or sorry, as an artist. Okay. So yeah. When did you start that?
Um, I stir that around my senior year of college. Um,
that's pretty late. I thought it would be earlier.
I think I was always kind of into it. Um, and then I think,
I think like in college, like there, there was like a dark moment in my life.
Um, and then I think I listened to Tupac a lot.
Like music does have the power to like change your mood or like brighten your
day. And so I, I just kinda want to contribute to that.
Yeah. So I see your shirt. You want to show the shirt to the camera real quick.
Cause it's freezer and yeah. So are you, we have.
I think we are blue is more for non-Asians.
Oh really? I love anime. Yeah.
So which, which ones? Which ones do you like?
Which ones do I like? I grew up with [inaudible] I think. Yeah.
Every DUI do you watch? My startup series? Uh,
rely on calendar.
I watched like one or something.
[inaudible].
Yeah. Yeah. So let's talk about music now. Um, so what,
so the music that you make, it's more like hype music, right?
You have some bars you can show me. Yeah. I think like it's,
it's going to be hard. Cause like I don't have a beat. I don't have anything,
but it's just raw voice. Do you think? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Yeah.
Let's start. Let's try something. All right.
I'm bumping with Joma in the studio had told him that we can
record a video. John was at Facebook. I'm at YouTube.
John was at Facebook, but he still do YouTube. Pipe it up.
Give it up for the interview. Hit the, like you already gave a view,
hit the sub. If you'd like the bars in,
if you are new making six figures cashing out only 22 that came
about after this going to get a tattoo probably of Gemma's face.
Think it's gonna make me.
Cool.
We only took like five takes. You know, that was, that was pretty good.
Not always one shot. And I was one shot. Okay. Let, let,
let me show you [inaudible] all right. All right. Okay.
So it was going to be embarrassing, but let me, let me, okay, doc,
let's be real. Are you plebs? Want to be like me? Want to be in demand?
Land jobs like me?
Want to run up at the term and code like me by ain't none of you mope was brain
good. Like me popping pills. Micro dosing. Just to be on my level.
But you broke as monkeys. Kevin Beck for the devil steal your jobs to your girl.
I'll make you a cuckold.
I cut up all that's the last line is not me then no one is sneaking in nausea
and I didn't finish it, but yeah, something like that. Okay.
Then you got some bars. Oh thanks bro. Yeah, of course.
And in verse two was like code. Tell the team I need more monies.
I got Gucci while you wear them company. T's free swag. Oh my God.
You're a code monkey. Keep typing. I caught shots like Steph Curry. Huh?
I use you your mom's I'm the cleverest in the game. Your average,
while you climb the ladder, I'm an Everest. Get your severance, find a job.
Here's a reference. And then it's like, yeah. Do you want a big four?
I don't care for, I got what you want when I was a sophomore.
You hating on my fame, but I never heard of you. You on blind, but the you.
Yeah, I think that was good. Wait,
so this was over the Nicki Minaj beat. Yeah. Well I'm going to be eyes.
I was actually like pretty good. Yay. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Also thank you to Seth for supporting this channel. Thank you so much.
And then also there's one question on Twitter, which is, Oh,
Hey gentlemen,
can you become a data scientist or analyst with a business degree?
That is yes.
And I'll just show you a proof of this person on LinkedIn that I found.
Okay, we're done. Actually,
this one also has a bachelor of arts and film and she became a data scientist at
Facebook. So, um, all right. So thanks for watching. If you liked this video,
don't forget to like and subscribe. And then if you like this guy,
don't forget to like and subscribe to his channel. I mean, he passed my bar,
so I'm down to promote channel.
What about this is keto kid. I'm stealing all of Jonah's viewers.
So if you with me, just check on my channel, he's going to put the thing.
So check out my latest music video.
What are you doing?
What kind of videos do you have there?
Uh, stuff with designer and.
Wait, what? Huh? Stuff with designer.
No, no, no, no, no, not that designer.
Like your typical designer and flexing.